I think we should start the show with uh
really I think the guy that's uh the
greatest show starter in the history of
the show you guys know anything about
the show that you're
at well you might know the words you
guys know the words for this guy's intro
song all right sing it if you know
it make some noise for H
everybody
thank you
guys so there was an eclipse recently I
love eclipses cuz I don't even have to
wear the
[Laughter]
glasses my eyes are always in Eclipse
mode I just have to side eye
it Israel is fighting Palestine again
winner has to fight Russia
loser has to marry Jada pinket
Smith and be backup dancers for
lizo suck that banana
palisin all right thank
you there you go 50 seconds of new
material from Hans Kim getting out 10
seconds early after a 2 we break
sorry about that Tony I am saving up for
the HB show it's going to be a great one
tune in yes for those of you that don't
know it is indeed happening the first
ever true uh Main Event comedy battle in
the history of Kil Tony for an already
sold out show it will be Hans Kim versus
golden ticket winner Rick Diaz and they
have decided they've put it all up on
the line one will be a full-time regular
of the show the other will not a snake
in Europe
yeah oh my goodness I absolutely love
this you guys have an internet beef and
everything you guys are promoting this
fight better than like Dylan danis and
uh Logan Paul did it's incredible update
the people if they don't know what's
been happening on the internet between
you two so on the internet uh Rick Diaz
has been a little [__] and he is about
you know oneth of the followers that I
have and I blocked him so I don't know
what the [__] he's
doing I have been killing it I have MC
Vader on my side making me posters I got
random people just giving me posters
with with Rick Diaz like getting [__]
in the ass and
[__] I've been wildly successful I've
been making money off of YouTube off
that clip
and wildly successful and you are you're
selling out everywhere you go adding
shows to these Comedy Club dates
incredible to think that only what 3
years ago sleeping in the van yeah not
doing anything with my life being a real
Rick
Diaz now this is a huge advantage that
you have over him while he's in Brussels
doing his day job you get to come here
every Monday and just talk [__] yeah
oops you [__] up
[__]
Hans oh my goodness repping the [__]
KT friends and family 10year anniversary
jacket you busted it out a little bit
early on a 78 degree
day I love it well like you it was also
made in China so no I'm kidding he's
Korean everybody he's Korean have you
talked to your parents lately no I sent
them $11,000 to my mom and you know that
keeps her happy so wait you're
supporting your parent don't they live
in Seattle yeah in San Francisco same
thing yeah why are you sending your mom
money just to be like thanks for raising
me here's like a a little loan repayment
you know I'm I'm repaying her back for
raising me that's nice that is nice but
you should stop
that how old are you 34 yeah 34 is a
little bit too late to be given 1,000
bucks here and there well three years
ago I was in a van I didn't really give
her anything was she giving you money
was she supporting you yeah she let me
live in her house for 5 years she left
for Korea I was in alone in this
beautiful condo for three years just
doing open mics and uh that really
helped my comedy career so I just want
to repay the investment she made in my
stock wow look at that 1,000 bucks
covers that I'd say huh free living for
3 years in a condo crazy here's 1,000
bucks where are you even send another
thousand bucks to San Francisco they
need it right
now yeah they really do what's their
situation are they Rich your parents
Rich yeah my sisters lived together uh
my mom lives with them you know she
lives in Oakland California she recently
had a bag stolen from her at a Costco
and we can I just do you mind yeah cuz I
thought you said are you rich and then I
heard him say yeah then I heard him say
my sisters live together and I don't
know any Rich [__] sisters that
live together you know what I'm saying
you said their their mom lives with them
too yeah that ain't Rich that sounds
like you know communal I got to send a
portion back to North Korea [__] in you
know what I
mean see your sisters live together
what's your dad like my dad is uh like
kind of
like what is that he's a Korean Santa
Claus he he he
oh what does that mean how you just
described your dad I he's like lovable
he's sort of like a sitcom dad he's like
oh dad always you know doing things that
are socially awkward like what can you
give us an
example
um
no I think raising him what have you
thought about sending your dad ,000 suck
no why is that my dad my dad is Rich my
dad is doing great he he know an
engineer he is a mathematician he's oh
God Lon no those guys are always the
life of the party
yeah he's always like farting like a
bubbly farts wait a second what does
that mean bubbly farts like wet farts
yeah very wet farts okay Red Band Jesus
Christ we have a I mean we
have literally we're 3 minutes into the
episode and you're busting out your fart
board
already okay my dad is great um my mom
and him are sort of separated he lives
in Korea alone your dad lives in Korea
alone yeah what do you think he's doing
over there exactly I hope having lots of
sex uh
I don't know what he's doing he has a
three-bedroom apartment to
[Laughter]
himself everybody else lives together
your dad's like [__] all of you I got
plenty of room and nobody's welcome here
he really is Korean Santa Claus he's got
ho ho hoes he's a rich [__] I [__]
love it a rich mathematician in Korea
there's a room for everybody Korea and
nobody's allowed to
go oh it's so good dude it's amazing
does your mom have a job yes she tutors
children in math oh my God this is the
most unbelievable stereotype that I've
ever heard mathematician and your mom
really tutors math for real if you tell
me she can't drive I'm going to lose my
[__]
mind she can drive she can yeah really
how about your sisters they they can
drive but they uh I don't know what
they're up to actually yeah we just
got we just got a live feed from their
uh driveway that's just the driveway so
imagine what's going on when they pull
all the way
out speaking of pulling all the way out
um your dad does he have any other kids
with any other women no it's just us
hopefully
hopefully okay no one would know if he
did like right yeah maybe he sends them
away and uses those
rooms U but no he's he seems like he's
pretty content he's got that surgery on
his eyes to make them bigger no way yeah
did he for real what yeah he said it was
for medical reasons what medical reasons
cuz his eyes were too
[Laughter]
small so he literally got the the like
the the eye opening they have an eye
opening like what do they do like trim
away your eyelids or something your eyes
really are closed I mean it is kind of
crazy I know we've been working together
for years and this is a weird time for
me to bring it up but holy [__] yeah
this is this is
me my goodness have you ever thought
about getting the surgery yes I would
love to get the surgery how much does it
cost I don't know it's not that much
,000 can you look up uh the anti-asian
surgery or whatever it's called
the
[__] not the dick lengthening one
Korean eyelid surgery price my
girlfriend wants it too oh my God it
really is $3,100 that a bad oh I could
get that oh in Korea in Korea it's only
$1,500 you could visit dad have an eye
openening
experience this is incredible you
could yeah
he's got room for you he's got two rooms
for you amazing Hans well so much fun
way to start the episode you did it
again you're so much fun living
legend the great the powerful Hans Kim
he makes it look easy I know I know it's
wild that was Hans Kim that was Hans Kim
that was Hans Kim all right your first
bucket full of the night ladies and
gentlemen now have you